c'est le magazine closer qui révèle
cette triste nouvelle la comédienne
mallaury nataf serait une nouvelle fois
dans une situation personnelle très
compliqué qui la forcerait à dormir dans
la rue il y a quelques années l'actrice
célèbre pour ses rôles dans les
productions ab avait réussi à remonter
la pente notamment en tournant l'année
passée dans la série les mystères de
l'amour sur tmc
aujourd'hui à 48 en retour à la case
départ toujours selon le magazine closer
l'actrice serait aujourd'hui en couple
avec un autre sdf établi dans le
quartier du marais les amoureux font la
manche pour tenter de survivre après une
période financière compliquée pour
l'actrice que l'épidémie de kobe 19 n'a
pas épargné mallaury nataf qui n'est pas
la seule célébrité à avoir connu une
situation aussi extrême
souvenez-vous il ya quelques mois à
peine c'est l'ancienne star de la
chanson ophélie winter qui s'était elle
aussi retrouvée à la rue
obligé de dormir dans sa voiture elle
s'était confiée sur notre plateau et le
les pactes de mon fils du tout et
partout
même topo pour loana qui n'a pas fini à
la rue mais qui a tout de même connu une
descente aux enfers spectaculaire toutes
les drogues qu'elle consomme aujourd'hui
elle va au suicide drogue violence
conjugale problèmes financiers prise de
poids alcool des difficultés qui l'ont
mené jusqu'à se faire interner en
hôpital psychiatrique
alors êtes vous choqué par les photos de
mallaury nataf dans la rue merci
benjamin d'argent d'être avec nous
rédacteur en chef de closer et c'est
vrai que cette histoire est elle est
folle parce que il ya plein de gens qui
se disent quand on nous voit à la télé
c'est qu'on gagne énormément d'argent
c'est con à l'abri du besoin et c'est
vrai que voir une actrice qui a fait des
années et des années de succès c'était
sur tf1 le miel et les abeilles
c'est vrai que c'est complètement fou
l'information est à vous est venu et
vous est venu comment sur balles au ring
c'est un concours de circonstances on la
noue à prier au mois de septembre
en tout cas voilà on avait eu
l'information mois de septembre on a
cherché à rentrer en contact avec l on a
appelé sur son portable qui était coupée
on lui a envoyé différents mails sur les
adresses qu'on avait à l'époque où on
était en contact avec elle
l'affluence aux revenus non distribués
donc voila et en fait on avait arrêté un
peu là parce qu'on était sur d'autres
sujets voilà et il ya quelques semaines
des photographes nous ont proposé ces
photos est-ce que vous avez hésité à les
publier
on s'est posé la question et fait mal
parce que les poteaux sont effectivement
très forte
ouais
après malheureusement pour mallaury
nataf ce n'est pas la première fois
qu'elle se retrouve dans cette situation
c'est un peu ce qu'elle vit depuis 2011
c'est à dire que depuis 2011
elle a vécu enfin en 2011 elle elle
avait déjà vécu trois ans dans la rue
c'est elle qu'il racontait elle même aux
journalistes
et voilà et on la suivait depuis cette
époque là on a suivi tous on a surtout
toute sa résurrection entre guillemets
son retour sur les plateaux des mystères
de l'amour est malheureusement là voilà
le les faits sont là allez de retenue il
ya beaucoup de stars comme ça qu'ils se
retrouvent à la rue comme ça qui est ce
que vous hésitez déjà à prendre des
photos comme ça comme nous l'avait dit
oui est-ce qu'il ya d'autres cas où il
ya d'autres cas assez récent on se
souvient l'année dernière il y avait
ophélie winter
ok tu es dans une période assez
difficile loana de manière assez
régulière se retrouvent dans des
situations alors elle est pas dans une
situation précarité comme mallaury nataf
mais elle est dans une situation
personnelle assez difficile et elle en
témoigner le même alors la question
qu'on vient de poser au chroniqueur chez
c'est la descente aux enfers des stars
c'est quoi la question n'est pas prêt à
vous mettez oui ou non est ce que les
jokers m'inquiète pas du tout moi j'ai
choqué évidemment parce que c'est très
triste pour elle mais mais alors il ya
différents cas de figure moi je vais
vous parler en fait et on parle de
bigard que les primes d'argent qui perd
alors c'est dans la tête des gens c'est
vrai que c'est choquant parce que mon a
gagné et regagne effectivement parfois
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
d'argent et on se dit mais comment
est-ce qu'on veut se prouver dans le
temps dans la merde quand on a gagné
autant d'argent pourquoi travailler
l'argent de côté que c'est fait vous
montrer un exemple qui est très simple
moi j'ai eu des problèmes parce que j'ai
fait des mauvais investissements
j'étais en fait avec les membres ont été
condamnés quand on est condamné on a des
saisies donc moi j'ai été donc cédé sur
mon salaire
moi j'avais un j'ai amené à fil de pêche
il y avait 22 mille euros bruts à tf1
alors vous aviez donc 22000 euros bruts
de salaire une alors voilà une fois que
vous êtes rentré dans le cycle où vous
êtes vous êtes saisis il vous laisse ce
qui est des bosquets une somme ils vous
laissent 1600 euros
sauf que moi à cette époque là j'ai
grandi les 20000 euros d'impôts à payer
j'ai écrit la maison j'ai des pensions
alimentaires donc j'ai un train de vie
assuré en fait en l'espace de dix douze
mois vous êtes encore plus dans la merde
que vous ne l'était en fait le sait est
infernal
on ne peut rien faire et quand on prend
conscience parce qu'effectivement il ya
un peu des go et un peu d'orgueil
évidemment on se dit voilà je suis
vedette
quand on ouvre les yeux c'est trop tard
donc moi je me suis battu parce
qu'effectivement gt gt voilà je suis
dans un combat juridique donc j'avais
d'abord j'étais paul et j'étais
conseiller mais si j'avais pas été dans
cette situation là si j'avais été un peu
faible se muter me apicole et cetera
j'aurais certainement finit très mal et
c'est pareil pour tout le monde si vous
avez 1200 euros de salaire on vous
enlève vous fait une saisie il vous
reste pas grand chose donc il faut pas
il faut pas blâmer des stars il faut
juste comprendre qu'effectivement on a
mené grand train on a fait des choses
moi effectivement j'ai profité de la vie
mais ce qui m'est arrivé je ne mérite
pas honnêtement que si les voilà
aujourd'hui j'ai fait de mauvais
investissements je fais de très mauvais
investissement
effectivement je n'ai pas été très
prévoyants mai mais le fait est qu au
final
pendant quatre ans que cyril ça a été
quand je vous dis un enfer c'est un
enfer c'est un combat à ce que les gens
ne comprennent pas ils pensent que vous
avez caché des lingots sommesous plus
mal que vous avez de l'argent à
l'étranger ce qui n'est pas le cas donc
maintenant j'avais même pas parce que
j'en suis arrivé à va déposer un dossier
de surendettement pour qu'on me fiche la
paix j'allais déposer un dossier ce qui
a été accepté parce que les gens parce
que j'ai mis très longtemps parce que
dans ma tête des gens il ya la télé tous
les jours ils gagnent de l'argent
qu'indécent donc c'est indécent bien sûr
que c'est indécent
sauf que si je fais pas ça je ne peux
pas m'en sortais aujourd'hui si on veut
si on me laisse pas respirer un peu je
vais crever moi j'aimerais que vous
n'aviez pas les mêmes taxes ni même plus
de carte bleue non mais j'ai moi j'ai
connu j'ai connu un truc dingue c'est
qu'effectivement j'ai été à la carte
bleue et vous n' ya pas vandales qui
sort alors sa pas durer ça peut durer
des années mais quand il ya la plaque il
avait emprunté à tous vos potes donc
vous n'avez plus personne vers qui vous
vous retournez effectivement pendant
pendant un mois il y avait plus de
chauffage à la maison mais comment
j'avais pu penser un jour que j'ai
imaginé le nombre de gens qui sont dans
votre calme et donc quand je vois ces
histoires là je comprends très bien moi
je me souviens les infos venait il y
avait sept cette couverture parce que
vous pouvez pas chauffé je vais pas
faire le plein mais quand vous racontez
ça on ne peut pas vous croire je vous le
dis franchement on ne vous croit pas
vous allez devant des justes qui ne vous
crois pas parce que c'est pas parce que
c'est pas audible cyril c'est vrai que
c'est possible quand on a eu la carrière
que j'ai eue quand on a fait ce que les
faits c'est pareil pour tous les
artistes quand ils ont fait ce qu'ils
ont fait dans leur vie on peut pas
entendre qu'un jour ça n'aille pas et
pourtant je vous le dit parfois
alors il ya ceux qui font des grosses
bêtises mais non mais souvent c'est pas
tellement des bêtises qu'on la roue se
met à tourner et qu'effectivement vous
êtes dans un dans un engrenage où on
vous prendra gorge c'est terminé et
c'est pareil pour tout le monde que vous
ayez 100000 dit
5000 ou 1000 c'est la même chose pour
tout le monde et tous les gens qui sont
dans la merde parce qu'effectivement ils
ont fait un un petit crédit pour le pour
le téléviseur pour la bagnole 1 pour les
ordis un jour monsieur monsieur c'est
fini eh ben ce moment-là qu'est ce qui
se passe
vous avez les huissiers vous avez des
comptes saisie les salaires saisis on
vous prend tout ce que vous avez et
s'est terminée fin de l'histoire alors
moi j'ai pu me battre parce que
effectivement j'étais conseiller mais il
ya plein de gens quand on faisait de
prix là dedans que c'est un enfer il
faut bien comprendre que c'est valable
pour tout le monde même si c'est
difficile à entendre
c'est pareil pour tout le monde est-ce
que vous avez des mecs qui vous ont aidé
bien sûr mais évidemment mais je vie
d'avant il ya des gens qui ont prêté de
l'argent doit encore je dois beaucoup
d'argent à plein de morts parce qu'ils
m'ont aidé au moment où il fallait
m'aider mais c'est très c'est très
humiliant et encore une fois c'est
compliqué de dire ah tu sais j'ai pu me
mets moi il me laissait quasiment rien
comment je fais alors un mois deux mois
trois mois et c'est très compliqué et
vous le savez puisque h2o vous avez vous
avez des saisies qui arrive très
régulièrement
on va voir pas sentir nous effectivement
c'est très compliqué alors on va passer
à la dernière partie de l'émission parti
j'ai une question à vous poser bourgeois
c'est parti ben jawad quand vous avez eu
ses propres problèmes d'argent est ce
que vous étiez encore que nous grandes
stars à 2 chez certains enfants passer
ça veut dire que jamais donc c'est ça le
paradoxe est que vous étiez sur tf1 bien
sûr
et est ce qu on le sait ces trucs là sur
les stars ou pas du canton travaillent à
closer to people en l'occurrence avec
benjamin castaldi ce qui est assez voilà
c'est qu'il l'a dit lui-même et il l'a
dit chez nous c'est à dire qu'un jour
j'étais venu pour faire une interview
castaldi et et une interview mais
vraiment pour parler voilà carrière
le taquiner un peu sur son mariage à
l'époque bien sûr voilà et là en fait je
me suis retrouvé devant l'animateur qui
me lâche ce qu' il est ruiné qu' il n'a
pas pu faire ses achats à noël pour ces
gamins et est là pour le coup c'était
assez courageux de sa part et je pense
que c'est un peu ce qui l'a sauvé dans
la mesure où l'accepter c'est déjà faire
un premier pas vers vers vers la sortie
du truc et que ce qui arrive parfois
en l'occurrence pour des stars qui tombe
vraiment bas c'est de ne jamais arriver
à l'accepter et se dire maintenant faut
que je me bouge faut je me sors tu fous
je m'en sors tu vois là alors on a vu on
a vu le cabas à la main castaldi
benjamin on va pas se mentir vous étiez
le numéro 3 en ut le numéro à tf1 donc
le numéro un du paf
donc on a vu jean marie bigard qui était
le numéro un à bien les jours
moisson juriste - quand tf1 vous allez
saisie qui arrive évidemment à la chaîne
ça n'arrange pas mes relations avec la
chaîne et quatre mois quatre ou cinq
mois après ils me cassent nos vies oui
effectivement c'est que ça à jouer qui
reçoivent des seizièmes évidemment
évidemment que ça à jouer parce
qu'effectivement on sait pas c'est pas
chic à se mentir c'est pas terrible
c'est un peu moi je m'en fous non mais
moi je vous dis non je voulais dire je
me moi je me mets moi aujourd'hui je
m'occupe je me cache plus et affective
maintenant je me bats monsieur organisé
pour que ce soit plus facile à vie parce
qu'effectivement avec heureusement la
loi vous permet de vous protéger mais
pendant des années je vous jure c'est un
enfer ces annonces avaient vécu quand
même temps comme ça sera sa durée 5 6
ans était très très très très très con
picking tray souvient nicolas pernikoff
probablement vous jouez le choco en
benjamins et il a été il a été courageux
alors c'est vrai que c'est très
compliqué c'est pour ça parce que qu'ils
l'expliquent si vous voulez il ya un
décalage bien ce jour le fait qu'il est
l'équipe qui soit quelqu'un d'important
qui est sur une chaîne de télé
quotidiennement et qu'il est un succès
d'audience
les gens n'arrivent pas à faire le recul
n'est comprendre ce qui peut lui arriver
mais cet engrenage moi j'ai connu
effectivement avec benjamin que je
connais depuis très longtemps mais j'ai
connu avec la une des plus grosses
fortunes de ce métier qui sont chantal
goya réjean la glmu ses vrais auteurs
compositeurs éditeurs interprète des
millions et des millions et des millions
d'albums vendus
le problème c'est qu'à un moment donné
quand vous saisi votre maison quand on
vous saisit tous et non repartir
derrière les anglais l'énergie est très
question question que je vous pose et
esquisser la question que doivent se
poser pas mal de téléspectateurs c'est
quand on a gagné énormément d'argent
d'accord vous pouvez vendre votre maison
vous cédez votre maison mais l'argent de
la maison il
parce que vous ne pouvez pas cumuler moi
je sais qu'il ya des gens je citerai pas
de nom voilà des gens qui se retrouver
sans rien qui ont gagné jusqu'à des 70
millions 80 millions d'euros meilleur
moi je n'ai pas de nom mais c'est très
simple vous avez vous avez un huissier
qui est un cas un acte juridique et qui
dit voile à la maison si vous la vendez
noah et c'est pour nous donc la maison
vous pouvez me contre sûrement pas
cumuler d'être comme ça c'est quand ça
se passe mais parce que on pense que ça
n'a quand vous commencez à avoir du
succès d'abord vous avez jamais prêt au
succès donc on pense que ça ne
s'arrêtera jamais j'ai jamais été c'est
pour ça que j'en ai jamais al'inverse
vous avez galéré
donc vous avez conscience vous avez
quand même on se connaissait rien moins
que lors de la vague qui a fait la
traversée du désert à bon port c'est une
très belle expérience à ça sert toujours
mais on pense que ça ne s'arrêtera
jamais et très souvent ce qui se passe
ce sont les impôts c'est à dire que ce
très souvent est très mal entouré tout
le monde se serre johnny enfin pour
beaucoup d'artistes c'est ce qui est
arrivé
vous avez des impôts qui vous tombent
dessus et à ce moment là si vous n'avez
pas les années derrière qui continuent
un peu salée c'est effectivement un
substrat normands ont fait passer en
général on paye pas les impôts les
comptables le nom d'artiste en
sortez-vous nantais parlant comptable
moi je suis monté à l'époque j'étais
mensualisés comme beaucoup de gens ouais
on vous laisse rien tous les mois le
problème d'impôts et pas payer donc le
mois d'après vous vous devez ce que
l'anuga mois d'avant et ainsi de suite
vous devez 300000 euros et ça vient
s'ajouter à tout le reste
non mais c'est très compliqué et
benjamin attendu surtout la loi borloo
parce que quand vous êtes endettés vous
attendez des mois et des mois et des
mois qu'on valide votre votre votre
faillite personnelle chez vous est très
intéressé pas de sujets sains chez vous
il ya beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
réactions oui sa team sincèrement pour
avoir vécu ça et en plus jeunes avec mes
parents je sais que c'est tellement
humiliant et je sais à quel point c'est
horrible de se retrouver c'est comme si
on est un peu dans un trou - on n'en
sort jamais et c'est terrible et le pire
c'est la façon dont les gens jugent en
fait c'est terrible et vraiment je vous
promets que c'était un réel traumatisme
pour moi et mes parents à l'époque et
que maintenant on s'en est sorti donc
tant mieux mais c'est vraiment que je
comprends benjamin castaldi dans le sens
où le ps et que coop c'est une
personnalité publique forcément les gens
vont juger
et forcément les gens vont dire ah il a
eu de la tune et moment il en a plus et
ça c'est terrible
le jugement porté là dessus il ya plein
de gens quand ils voient des stars à la
rue comme ça qu'ils doivent se dire mais
pourquoi ils vont pas faire un job entre
guillemets normale et cerci pourquoi il
exactement
il faut savoir quand vous avez connu la
gloire le succès que vous avez été
chouchouté par tout le monde que tout le
monde venez vous faire entre guillemets
de la lèche c'est extrêmement dur de
revenir à la société normal moi j'ai
connu quelqu'un ya pas longtemps une
ancienne gloire évidemment je citerai
pas son nom qui m'a demandé de l'aider
un peu lui donner un petit boulot est en
fait donc je lui ai fait je les fais
mais cette personne n'arrivait pas à
retravailler normalement à se lever le
matin à venir à 8 heures au bureau à
avoir un mode de vie normal on est
déconnecté
mais c'est oui c'est encore moins
évident je n'ai pas vécu mais c'est
extrêmement dur gelé revenir à la
société normale parce que en fait je
pense que les gens ont une mauvaise
influence autour de vous il ya tout un
entourage autour de vous qui vous dit
que du bien de vous donc vous pensez que
vous êtes une grande star hébergement je
pense que tu confirmes ya pas j'ai une
chance et j'ai toujours travaillé après
moi car il conseillé de m'appeler la
première fois sur ces huit pas vous
mentir quand il m'a dit viens faire
chroniqueur je vous dis par ego et par
orgueil je vous ai dit d'aller vous
faire [ __ ]
mais ça c'est typiquement de les loger
barça avait plus rien aujourd'hui ce que
tu pourrais redevenir un peu je sais pas
peut-être vendeurs serveurs un match
normal j'en sais rien ça fait ça fait 25
ans que je fais ce que je bosse à la
démission que ça s'arrête le reste j'ai
plein de projets en route tu fais
d'autres choses jeu mais bon c'est très
courageux de la raison c'est impossible
pas sûr non c'est pas vrai vous les
voulez réagir en l'occurrence alors il a
atteint fall a essayé de d'avoir un
boulot un job normal elle l'avait
raconté d'être boulangère caissière
enfin d'aller bosser en jeu pour la
travailler dans une boulangerie et alors
elle a expliqué qu'en fait elle le
faisait un mois deux mois et que les
gens là reconnaissait et que du même
sacré un espèce de troubles parce que ça
vaut pascal alors lui il a été énorme
star de la star ac mais il ya des plus
connus je vais vous dire quelque chose
passe quelque chose qu'ils sont pas moi
j'ai été pendus c'est vrai au décès de
mon père je vais vous dire je devais
185000 aux impôts alors si j'ai perdu
mon contrat tf1 à un moment que j'étais
salarié de tf1 en tant qu'animateur je
vais sanou balle par mois j'ai perdu mon
contrat tf1 je devais 185 1000 euros par
chance mon père m'avait fait acheter un
terrain j'ai pu redémarrer les
redémarrer à zéro
et puis j'ai eu une base il ya huit ans
je n'avais rien je pense que les gens
aussi les stars comme on dit
il faut pas avoir peur de redémarrer de
se dire mais je fais de la télé
qu'est ce que je sais faire d'autre j'ai
ouvert un petit resto ça a moyennement
marché j'ai vendu j'ai fait serveur dans
un restaurant les gens toute la journée
vous dise ah ça vous mène là la télé les
gens sont des connards j'étais un an et
demi au restaurant du golf de chantaco
qui m'a pris et après syrie tu m'as pris
et c'est pour ça je te le dis je le dis
avec émotion parce que ça n'a pas été
facile et je suis passé par des moments
hyper dur et j'ai quand même eu la
chance de delphine qui s'est occupée de
mes enfants j'ai galéré à payer mon
loyer j'en ai chié mais je veux dire un
truc c'est pas parce qu'on fait de la
télé on peut pas être boulanger ou
autres parce que les gens la
reconnaissaient ne riez pas quand il
faut bouffer et ses défauts de bouffer
mais que soit serveurs électricien
boulanger n'y a pas de sous métier il
faut s'adapter
donc moi ces gens là au bout d'un moment
et je les plains pas passifs avoir les
couilles de dire eh ben il faut faire
autre chose et ça redémarrera et la
preuve c'est le jura démarrer c'est dur
mais si on se bat on peut y arriver
voilà jean pascal non mais c'est bien ce
que vous dites moi ce qui ce qui m'a ce
qui m'a marqué c'est fastoche vous étiez
serveurs et donc là les gens
n'arrêtaient pas de vous dire ouais
qu'est ce que tu fais en fait ça a dû
vous des primeurs à fou oui parce que
c'est au moment où j'ai divorcé de ça
c'était compliqué et les gens ils les
gens ils vous demandent mais même
aujourd'hui c'est pas un truc fastoche
tu vois c'est quand tu m'appeler de le
faire maintenant
mais là bas mais je sais mais c'est une
chance que tu vas bien je dis donc je
veux dire quand on se bat on peut
toujours y arriver voilà je ne suis pas
du genre j'aime pas je n'aime pas ce
chalet au coin mais quand on veut se
bouger le cul bon on peut toujours
essayer d'arriver et il faut pas écouter
les autoriser ou à regarder où ça mène
la télé tout ça en rigolant mais ses
sacs et ses carrés vip fontenay syrie
tous les jours en ce qui concerne rouge
quelques choix ici parce que parce que
je peux pas aller ailleurs tous les
jours et où nous avait des tweets avec
mais c'est pas très grave à la limite
c'est pas très grave mais c'est vrai que
mine de rien il faut il faut accepter
des choses qu'elle change quoi faire
d'autre chose moi j'ai fait j'ai fait
des choses qui étaient très vivant de
télévision après on m'a rappelé mais
c'est une chance énorme et moi j'ai moi
j'ai en moi j'ai revu jean pascal il
avait un petit restaurant de bien mais
un petit cabanon est venu me voir
yang et il m'a servi un verre d'un petit
verre de tir de champagne à boire avec
modération car vous n'avez pas parce que
vous aussi vous avez une carrière non
mais vous vous avez toujours travail non
moi j'ai toujours travaillé je travaille
et où il ya eu une parenthèse de
quelques mois de brouille audio très bon
de te cacherai des mois deux mois
d'attenté virer tf1 c'est ça non mais
j'avais la radio et puis j'ai repris la
télé très vite je voulais dire par
rapport ce qui est difficile pour
justement qu'on passe à la télé ou pas
de retrouver un job normal comme tout le
monde
parce qu'en fait valve mallaury nataf a
été viré de la boulangerie voulaient y
rester elle avait enfin trouvé un petit
appartement elle réussissait un peu payé
tous ses frais sauf que le mec il a viré
parce que c'était l'enfer dans la
boulangerie et qui pouvaient pas la
garde et à cause de ça mais elle est
revenue dans la série elle est revenue
mais c'est elle qui a décidé de partir
oui c'est jean luc azoulay qu'il a dit
là où je rejoins jean pascal
c'est que il ya des célébrités comme ça
qu à qui on a proposé des aides
effectivement jean luc azoulay l'a aidé
moi je sais que par exemple loana je les
rencontrais plusieurs fois je vais
proposer de l'aide juridique bien on
travaille ensemble si tu veux te
développe etc c'est des gens qui vont
malheureusement décroche tellement parce
qu'ils sont tellement pas entouré qu'en
fait il s'habitue à cette vie là et qui
ne veulent pas s'en sortir aussi pour
certains et là où je rejoins jean pascal
c'est que quand on a des enfants qu'on
doit leur donner à manger etc
on se sort les doigts des fesses excusez
moi de l'expression et on va bosser
parce qu'on n'a pas le choix c'est une
question de survie
gomis c est un roman je t elle le regard
des autres moi j'ai connu un chanteur
qui a fait des chansons pour dutronc
pour hardy qui a été vraiment une
immense vedette
et effectivement il est devenu serveur
dans le quartier des halles de paris
et c'est vrai que les chambres les gens
lui chier dessus tout la journée de
garde à vue ce camp la mnam tu laves le
seul d'où le solde du compte j'ai
entendu mes mp folles les gens alors
c'était pas méchant méchant mais c'était
toi et regarde erick bamy on parlait de
la doublure de johnny qui s'est retrouvé
dans une des chais pouvant table de sang
qu'il avait pris les habitudes de vie de
johnny il devient après il est replacé à
la france a un incroyable talent pour se
relancer vers me rappelez vous de cet
animateur lionel cassant bien sûr il est
le castor c'est un animateur sur france
2 ouais qui a été un grands animateurs
ils avaient toutes les matinales et ses
bains il s'est suicidé il s'est
carrément suicider parce qu'on l'a
retrouvé il a été commentateur un peu
chez michou il a fait des petits jobs et
les gens se foutent de sa gueule toute
la journée et un jour j'ai croisé il
était en larmes il me dit c'est bernard
je n'en peux plus les gens n'acceptent
pas cette
vie moi non plus j'ai pas un rond se
fout de ma gueule toute la journée et il
s'est suicidé
benjamin quand vous avez trouvé la force
ou de repartir parce que j'avais des
enfants j'ai eu la chance qu'on
m'appelle pour cela veut dire moment je
fais tout fait je vais arrêter
évidemment des jeux on pense au pire
c'est vrai bah ouais ouais on n'y pense
pas longtemps on se dit voilà c'est fait
ce qui est compliqué c'est le
harcèlement permanent et surtout qu'on
ne vous qu'on vous écoute pas et qu'on
ne vous crois pas donc moi je vais vous
expliquer rap a expliqué re expliqué
après moi j'ai toujours pas mal de
chance
d'abord je suis entouré j'ai ma main
puis j'ai été appelé pour faire un
boulot à sanguinet ce qui m'a permis en
fait de rester en vie mentalement c'est
quand en plus quand vous êtes donc on
est harcelé si vous êtes plus en forme
physiquement si vous aussi si tout se
casse la gueule alors fait plus télé du
tout et c'est comme ça qu'on se retourne
dans d'un dans un cercle infernal si
vous êtes plus en forme
vous mettez à picoler faire des
conneries et et les gens du bas voilà le
maigre année ses loques m'étais
grognards aux immigrés témoigne un
pestiféré pour la télé les gens et on
évite langer pas été investis vg encore
une fois j'ai fait je fais départ et
j'ai accepté un truc sur gulli par
exemple j'ai fait une seule sur gulli
c'était un gros carton bon j'ai de la
chance et après mais je me suis j'ai
fait une chose avec moi c'est que je
quand j'étais vraiment dans la merde
kenny faut que je me prenne le chemin de
soin de moi aucun élément ne suis pas
bien bouffer comme un cochon j'ai pas
fais à l'âge mais j'ai fait du sport et
ça c'est la clé être en forme
physiquement et c'est vrai que dans ceux
pour qui ça va mal souvent le physique
oui la déchéance décline voit la série
les jeux c'est pour finir parce que par
rapport aux comédiens il ya plein de
comédiens que vous voyez à la télévision
s'ils s'arrêtent de bosser si besoin
pendant un an ils n'ont plus rien porter
de penser que ces métiers des lentilles
dans la lumière
ils ont ils ont gagné de l'argent à tout
pouvoir travailler jamais ils ont besoin
de bosser tout le temps c'est pour ça
que c'est compliqué pour les
intermittents et c'est pour ça que pour
les comédiens et des gens qui sont
connus c'est très compliqué ce qui se
passe en ce moment
oui j'avais un rêve dans ma vie moi
c'était de rencontrer michel galabru
voilà 21 jours et rencontrer michel
galabru et maman il m'a expliqué
pourquoi il avait fait autant de navets
dans sa vie et me dit vous savez combien
nicolas j'ai tourné 2
de temps dans ma vie deux ans et vous
savez pourquoi parce qu au mois de mai
au mois de juin
j'avais mes enfants qui me demandaient
où on allait en vacances et je n'avais
pas d'argent devant moi et je pouvais
même pas bouffer et je prenais le
premier film qu'on me proposait pour
pouvoir leur offrir des vacances il a
tourné deux ans dans sa vie cet homme
qui était un des plus grands acteurs
français a vécu toute sa vie quasiment
au bord de la ruine
c'est fou ban à un mot sur mallaury
nataf j'ai appelé aujourd'hui et
princess erika qui axent chanteuse et
comédienne qui est de sa meilleure amie
se sont rencontrés sur la ferme la ferme
célébrités elle me dit mais cela dit
mallory je sais pas si elle est vraiment
vraiment malheureuse parce qu'elle a
toujours été anti système est saturé et
une femme libre et qu'elle a perdu la
garde
il dit qu'elle est attaché à la religion
de façon mystique peut-être même envie
d'y aller ce sont les mots de jean luc
azoulay pas les miens jean pascal il
foot aux témoignages toi tu as pensé
arrêter là voilà comment tu t'es dit je
vais revenir hanter c'est toi tu penses
c'est voyant ton talent c'est toi qui
m'a fait revenir à l'intérieur aussi
l'utiliser
non j'ai déjà arrêté sino quand tu
m'appeler c'était le confinement et
après voilà je mets j'avais arrêté il ya
un an quand quand t'as plus rien et tu
es une femme des enfants ma femme
delphine travail et j'avais des enfants
mettant un loyer qui était cher tu dis
il faut une maison plus petite donc il
faut il faut trouver un métier et mais
j'ai de la chance parce que j'ai réussi
après voilà je suis allé j'ai frappe à
peine porte on a dit non non non non
j'avais un truc de comptabilité j'étais
un truc pour être plâtrier et puis comme
gmail ou gold j'ai été voir le
restaurant du golf de chantaco à
saint-jean-de-luz je ne cherchais pas un
serveur est rongé le patron m'a dit oui
au début je lui ai dit je dis prenez moi
laisser gratuitement trois quatre jours
si je suis bon vont embaucher
le mec il me dit d'accord donc tu
appréhendes tu apprends à te dire
mamadou mais arrête tu as dit qui est
pas du tout par contre c'est les gens
autour qui toutes les garnisons ce kit
enfance et le soir tu rentres et puis
étaient enfants ils te disent mais tu
gagnes 1500 mal c'est un loyer de 1270
et puis il faut que la verte était en
forme alors tu fais mais c'est le
salaire voilà mes donc je me mets à la
place de tommy je veux dire que on peut
toujours rêver donc c'est pas facile
parce que j'aime pas moi parler tout ça
parce que je me c'est pour ça je suis
toujours le rigolo parce que je me calme
tout ça mais voilà quand on veut y
arriver un peu mais c'est si tu m'avais
pas appelé je serai encore là bas j'y
arriverais et j'aurais fait autre chose
et on avance c'est comme si j'avais pu à
starace pas ce que j'aurais fait mais
c'est pour ça que je suis très heureux
d'être là et que je l'économie voilà
donc et on peut y arriver on peut c'est
dur quand même faut peser ses mots parce
qu'il y en a comme loana ou comme à
l'ordinateur qui sont dans une détresse
psychologique n'était pas aussi le
magasin il ya des deux pays ont des
droits comme tu dit magali procure manas
qui est gênant c'est que là où je
comprends jean pascal sait que lohan on
lui a proposé de l'aide ou mercier la
nouvelle est entouré de sa femme aussi
qu'il manque c'est plus profond que ça
c'est comme si je suis dit je veux voir
une personne qui est sans domicile fixe
je lui donnais voilà ou 30 euros à
passer mon tablier régler non voilà un
suivi psychologique les accompagnaient
ont leur trouver du travail c'est bien
plus profond que tiens voilà un peu
d'argent on la travaille démerde toi
elle est traumatisée qu'elle a vécu